why mindset matters I think lack of
belief is the world's biggest problem
right whether you believe you can or you
can't you're right and most people are
just stuck most people feel trapped most
people are around other negative people
who also feel trapped and so you might
occasionally have this idea that great
things are possible but then you fall
back to the negative mindset and
everybody else around you and you stay
stuck I just came back from a from
speaking at two events in Phoenix a
genius Network and the first one people
pay 25 000 a year to be in the second
one and you pay a hundred thousand
dollars to be in my last day I had a
morning coffee with a guy who had sold
his business for over 200 million
dollars
and now is helping other entrepreneurs
be more efficient and productive in
their businesses and he picked me up
from my hotel and we drove to his house
and his house is more like a compound
he's just not just a house it's like a
house and then an entire house just for
his reporting Studio plays guitar in
another house just for his Taekwondo
studio for him to practice and like four
houses and one house and
more than any bit of advice that he gave
me and similar to just being in those
groups it's the the mindset difference
it's like trying to do
life at a bigger level trying to have an
impact at a bigger level and for most of
us we are that source of positivity for
other people we are the ones believing
in other people and pouring into other
people and telling them that they can do
it and giving them love and
encouragement and support but who's
telling us that we can do better and in
a loving way not like you should be
doing this to assist we got lots of
those people but who's pushing your
loving way forward and for the most part
we don't have those people so that's why
I love a group like this that's why I
love groups like movement makers
um and just in general trying to be
around more optimistic positive people
because sometimes it's hard for Carrie
for us to carry the whole burden of
positivity and optimism for ourselves
and so if you are the most optimistic
person you know that's in your immediate
circle
um that's a problem you know like it's
great that you can don't stop pointing
other people but if you don't have
anybody who's pouring into you then that
keeps us stuck and it keeps us small and
so the mindset shift to feel like hey I
can do more I can be more I can serve
more I can have a bigger impact
um I think becomes really important so
the the whole idea of you are the five
people you surround yourself with really
matters and if you don't know anybody
then get in a group or come back to you
know group like this
um or even just through content
right that I haven't met Elon Musk yet
but I I get inspired by his videos and
his content and his moves like Elon Musk
is buying Twitter what doesn't he
already have four of the companies that
he's running or something just like it
just makes me question what I'm doing
not in a negative way like I think
comparison actually can be really
beneficial a lot of people say don't
compare yourself to others and I think
people just compare themselves
incorrectly they look at somebody else
and then they kick themselves down say I
can't do it where I like it as a kick
forward say wow look what Elon Musk is
doing I can I should be thinking bigger
and it's an inspiration to go off and do
more otherwise we stay stuck and stay
small
um so anyway that's my little quick Riff
on why mindset matters thank you Samar
for the topic and uh let's let's open it
up Tony's got his hand up what do we got
Tony
I have a personal training and nursing
coaching business for 35 years now and
for 33 years I was doing everything in
person until covet hit switched
everything virtual and online
but for probably the past eight years
since I was about 45-ish years of age
I've been posting non-stop Monday
through Friday on Facebook I've been
emailing Monday
through Friday to meals I started doing
Instagram maybe a couple years ago as
well I feel lost in that kind of virtual
world so
we went through a great exercise this
morning Movie Makers where I'm I'm
basically I told them that my number two
platform is now Tick Tock we decided
last week that YouTube is number one and
it still is number one by far but I've
switched in the past week from Instagram
to tick tock as number two and so part
of it is being smart with where you're
at because you could you could be
producing the best content ever but if
you're on Facebook like Facebook has
been dead for a long time right there's
no zero organic reach on Facebook it's a
fantastic ad platform but it sucks for
Content
um
Instagram
is
slowly not dying but becoming less and
less and less and less and less relevant
it's harder to rank it's harder to win
um we covered a little bit today but the
reels is still going to be your best bet
now like no more pictures it's reels so
I need to see reels I need to see short
form video content
um and then Tick Tock is definitely
picking up steam like we're over half a
million followers on Tick Tock and a
quarter million on on Instagram and
it's taken me like six years to do that
on Instagram in a year and a half or
whatever on Tick Tock and we're barely
taking Tick Tock seriously right like
Instagram's been number one and we just
kind of post whatever to tick tock and
the thing is blowing up
um and it's becoming an education place
as well for people so it's not just
somebody commented like 16 year old
teenagers dancing or whatever they're
still that and there's fun but it's also
becoming an education platform and the
the easiest thing to do is go search for
what you're doing
what you teach and and see what's on
there and you'll see that hey there's
actually education content on there so I
love that you're making content I love
that you're an expert you've been doing
this for so long and you want to serve
um I would look at
if I was getting started now and I
didn't have traction I would do YouTube
long form
and Tick Tock short form but then I
bring to the other platforms
um I would probably completely abandon
Facebook unless it was just easy to post
or you had some kind of community there
already
um and the long-form YouTube videos
would be
not hugely impactful in the short term
but you've been doing this for a while
and you want to keep doing this and so
um
getting whether they're actual workout
videos that you're going to do whether
they're coaching sessions that you have
with clients uh you're imagine someone's
going to see this in a year and two
years and three years and love what
you're doing and sign up YouTube is the
if you want to get off the kind of rat
race you know the hamster wheel whatever
YouTube is it because when you make
content in a year it's still relevant
and valuable and can drive traffic every
other platform is it's insta like
Instagram it's instant it's only what's
happening right right right right right
now doesn't mean that I can't help or
can't convert but Choice a platform in
in choice of content like if you're
doing pictures on Instagram it's just
gone off a cliff
so it's short form video Everybody Wants
short form video now plus long form on
YouTube so I'd look at a if you're not
consistent on YouTube yet I'd look at
once a week making content 10 minutes
plus no upper limit on how long you can
go
and then a daily short form for tick
tock that then you take to the other
platforms
great thank you okay let's move on lady
Lexi what do we got hi there okay
um
today is the Dutch Liberation day 77
years ago there are a number of
festivals they are still going you see
Liberation day yeah Dutch Liberation day
okay great well happy happy Liberation
day yeah so that's my fifth and um which
I think oh no I'm like I need to go to
Rotterdam go to one of those festivals
and make a recording but I'm like okay
what exactly am I going to talk about I
cannot just address all the people there
because I don't have a fresh batch or
anything so how do I make that work
because I feel like it's so important
that we get to speak out and and so I
can either go there or I can do it from
here what what would you suggest what
hold on what are you speaking out again
so it's okay Dutch Independence Day cool
today is 77th anniversary oh that we got
liberated by the English and by the
Americans and there might definitely
even be some Canadian
okay so the idea is hey you need to like
you want to recognize them
haven't I don't was a revolution or was
it a you know like how like they're
speaking up for themselves
it's so important
and I mean especially when with what's
going on in the Ukraine it makes my
heart cry since my my mother is about
speaking up and speaking out this is
about people back then were of course
being uh uh delegated basically to to to
the to the camps and put work there and
they were not recognized as people
so it's not necessarily that I want to
speak out for what happened there I just
want to you know say like okay let's
celebrate freedom let's remember that
it's important that we do speak up and
speak out
what we what we see and what we find
should change and also on a personal
level
so I mean that could be a great so if
the message is speaking out for Freedom
then that's something that people can
connect with because we want to Target
ideally the world not just
Holland right so most people wouldn't
know that it's dutch Independence Day or
how many however many years it's been or
how Holland even came out of you know
like most people know the story and the
story
Almost Doesn't Matter unless it really
means something to you but if you were
gonna go and make it not just what
happened 77 years ago but where did
people need more freedom right now like
it's a good trigger as a reminder so I'm
Canadian and but like we don't um we
don't we have we have Canada day but
it's not really that big a deal in
Canada
um but Americans take their independence
day pretty seriously right and so on
July 4th in America if you were to go
off and talk to people about about
freedom
but then make it reflective as to where
do you not have enough freedom in your
life right now
and not just from like the government
imposing something on you but your own
situation like where are you stuck in a
relationship are you stuck in a bad
career are you stuck in bad habits are
you stuck with an addiction like if you
can tie the need for freedom to
something they're facing right now in
their life then it can lead to speaking
up like for yourself if you're in a bad
relationship hey maybe you need to get
out if you're in a bad career maybe now
is the time so you can use this event as
a spark plug to create some change so
you could go if you want to go to the
event you don't need a you don't need a
press badge to talk to people
you just go on the street and you ask
people about what Freedom means to them
but then make it relevant to today I was
like well where do you not have enough
Freedom right now do you think in your
life
and then guiding them to a path of
speaking up
okay uh okay yeah it's going to be a big
step for me you know addressing people
randomly at a festival
um but yeah listen lean in on that
because this is now you speaking up
yeah that's good yeah it's a good
challenge absolutely this is I've never
done it before and this is now you
going after your freedom because you
don't want to be you don't want to have
that blocking mindset anymore
yeah and you may have people who say no
and I want to talk to you no I hate you
I mean whatever you're like speaking
like worst case scenario
um but you'll have some people who will
talk to you
yeah yeah that's nice and then maybe I
can do some shorts some short lives and
then later on make it into a big one and
post it on YouTube honestly the biggest
thing the biggest win out of all of this
isn't the content you're going to get
from them it's from you pushing yourself
outside the comfort zone
okay that makes sense the fact that like
one person might say yes to you and
you're so scared to ask people to come
on and then you get one person to do it
even if it's not the greatest
conversation of all time like that
forward momentum and you breaking
through like that should be a video you
should film yourself going
and how scared you are and what whatever
thoughts are in your head
and you're basically speaking up to your
own thoughts to say you know what no I'm
gonna I'm gonna go do this and even if I
if I embarrass myself if nobody talks to
me
I'm still gonna go off and do it I saw a
great clip yesterday on Instagram where
um these these um this guy was a
stutterer
so like he gets nervous and then he
can't talk and and his coach I know you
guys have seen this this coach had him
go out in a busy area and
go up to people and ask them to like hey
can you help me for a second and all he
then would ask him is what time is it
but it took him forever to get it out
because he was so nervous and when he
gets nervous he starts to stutter and so
he's like excuse me
like they're sitting there waiting for
him to like what's going on right now
and eventually he says you know what
time is it and
um he also just shared the story with
them like I must I'm a stutterer and I'm
trying to
be less scared and stutter less as this
is part of my my homework
so even you sharing your story like
that's like the biggest win of all is
you share in your story that where
you're afraid and the mental block
um so that you get your own freedom from
those limiting thoughts too
yeah that's good one so I can just take
my phone I don't need any microphones or
anything right yeah especially if you're
doing two people because if the
microphone's just here then it's harder
to share
and don't worry about the gear just go
do it
okay yeah I'll do thank you I love it
cool good luck that's super exciting
how long would you take and what exact
steps would you take to build a list of
a few hundred people serve and launch
what they need so as a starting point I
would pick a platform
where do you like to engage you know if
you're going to be YouTube Instagram
Twitter LinkedIn if you're talking about
how do I get a few hundred people to
know about me where do you like to
engage Clubhouse is what we talked about
today movement makers where do you like
to engage and then you can have a little
bit of content but I think the best
thing if you're just trying to build a
couple hundred people is to go and
connect with people on other people's
accounts so you're leaving comments on
YouTube you're leaving comments on
Instagram you're you're responding to
people on Twitter you're joining
people's rooms on clubhouse you're dming
people on Instagram right you pay
attention to the platform just pick one
platform and then give as much value as
possible so that they want to connect
with you they want to follow you they
want to see what you're up to they want
they love the energy right a lot of this
is just an energy game
part of why you guys are here too is
like there's an energy every week that
we get to do this you know with me with
Zane with the whole group uh that people
need that and people need your energy
they need the the love and the the yes
the strategies but they need the hope
and the belief that you can give them by
hanging out with you they feel fired up
to go do something else that it doesn't
just have to be motivation rah-rah but
just the fact that you're there
listening supporting cheering them could
be enough to have them take one extra
step
so that's what we do at the beginning
you start leaving comments thanking
people saying hi giving your opinion
feedback thought suggestions and people
start to connect with you and follow you
the next thing I would do again just to
answer this question from salima that
you guys voted on is I would try to get
on some calls with them to figure out
what they're struggling with if you're
trying to figure out what their how can
you serve and launch what they need get
on some calls either Zoom calls to get
to know them better say hey thank you
for following me I love to learn more
about what your business is all about
and how I might be able to give some
guidance feedback help suggestions
so Zoom calls are a great way to get to
know people I default to public stuff so
I don't I barely do any private Zoom
calls if somebody's asking me for help
um if it's if it's like a high high up
person okay fine we'll do a private Zoom
but for the most part it's like okay
let's do this on live
let's go live on Instagram and figure
this out or join me on the live stream
where we do I do my gaming with with Zan
and Drew four days a week at night
coming coming live and ask us questions
uh or for somebody in this group it's
like hey come to The Insider's readers
group
and ask your question and the more that
you actually start connecting with
people the more you'll start to figure
out
what the challenges are and how you can
help them there Comes This Moment where
this is why I love recommending doing
coaching first before anything else So
for anybody who wants to write a book do
speaking have courses have materials all
of that if you can start with coaching
that lets you try out your ideas on
somebody more than you
because it worked a certain way for you
it's not going to work that way for
everybody else you have the way that it
works for you
and there's a certain number of people
who can fit into that exact same way
but as you start talking to people and
coaching them and working with them
you'll find other paths to be able to
help them which then makes your book
more powerful which then makes your
courses more powerful you're training
more powerful so as a quick example
um when I was writing your one word my
first book this is the book this right
here was the original book this thing is
crazy this is a hundred and forty
thousand words that we then cut half the
book got cut to seventy thousand words
but this is the one of the original 30
copies of the book that I printed off
and and gave to my test audience to read
um one of the things in your one word
was
helping people find their one word which
is their who right that that transition
to becoming Yahoo there was one guy I
met in a coffee shop named Derek here in
Toronto and I was helping him through
the who process it's okay this is it
this is easy here you go let's ask him
questions the five questions you know
what did you love about your parents and
who's your favorite teacher and your
favorite movie and all of these things
right the usual question that worked for
that work for people he's like I can't
get it I don't know I I can't figure it
out and so I'm struggling sitting there
in the Starbucks trying to help him
figure out what his who was and then I
realized okay let's just try something
out of left field how about we go
negative instead of all the positive
things how about we go negative like who
are the not the people who you love and
why who are the people that you hate and
not that they're bad people but but who
do you hate or what is it about them
that you hate to think about the people
your worst teacher the person at school
that you hated the most the colleague or
boss that you hated the most that you
don't want to spend time with them great
what are what are those characteristics
and then the opposite
so when we figure that out that's that's
what I call the anti-word and then the
opposite is is your who is your one word
um and so
that coaching process led to a change in
how I wrote the book
because for me I it's easy to default to
the positive I don't think about the
people I hate I'd have to struggle to go
back and like huh who do I hate and why
but for some people will and it's easier
for them to figure out their path so
ultimately I you know I want to serve
you guys want to serve as well so that's
where you've got your methodology that
you know worked for you and can work for
a small percentage of people but when
you start actually talking to people
coaching and helping them you'll say
what worked for you but it's not going
to quite fit that hat won't quite fit
you know so the more that you can do the
coaching you'll get a couple more ideas
of how to be able to reach people by
workshopping it with them and then that
makes you a better Coach but it makes
your products better your books better
your your service is better your your
everything makes it all better because
now you've actually worked with people
through it as opposed to only having
helped yourself
so the more you can actually start to
get some feedback that may feel slow at
the beginning because you've got to talk
to people
but all of those things help make you
better for your ultimate Ambitions of
when I'm speaking on stage if there's I
did one yesterday we did a virtual
coaching Summit it's like a thousand
people or something in the room
um when I'm talking to them
I know the messages work because I've
I've said the same message to A Thousand
other people before on the one-on-ones
right so that's what allows you to scale
and hit a message so talking to a group
of people is really just talking to a
bunch of individuals
um so I hope that helped that was a fun
little topic salima I hope that gave you
some value whoever's got a question
raise your hand i'm Mike and let's do it
Evan is ready to go okay what do you got
man I do have a question
um I was saying before you got on I've
had very limited time because I've just
been so busy in my business and can't
find employees nobody wants to work
whatever
so the little bit of content I have done
I feel like I'm repeating myself
um because of like you know my story and
kind of like what my core is but it
feels stale to myself
like on how to mix up the same message
if that is your message without sounding
repetitive to those of you who might
follow on a regular basis you know what
I mean yeah so a couple things new but
not turn off the the existing I know I
hear you man listen I've done over 10
000 videos
about belief
there's a lot of repetition like there's
only so many unique stories you can
share about believe you know ten
thousand times so a couple things that
helped me one
um
recognize that even though it feels new
for you it's not new for the audience
right so there's always new people
who've never heard this message before
and they need to hear it so just the
fact that you said something two weeks
ago
a lot of people haven't heard it yet and
the way you know the YouTube algorithm
and Instagram algorithm and every
algorithm works it's only hitting a
small percentage of the same people
every time so
you have to love the students more than
the material
right so if you'd like how to teach or
how do how does your favorite teacher
growing up teach the same history class
every year for 20 years and not just go
bored out of their mind it's the same
content
because it's not about the contents
about the student it's different
students every time they love the
teaching process and so it's about
getting out of your head and into the
audience's head like they haven't heard
this before so I'm going to show up for
them because because I know you and I've
seen you in action I see how much you
care and love I go people want to see
how much you're always trying to raise
your hand and like get involved to serve
and share your story
you're just if it's just you in a in
your office by yourself or in the car or
whatever it can sometimes be hard to
make that connection or if it was
somebody if Angel was sitting there in
front of you and you're sharing your you
know recovery story it wouldn't feel
like it's repetition because you see
Andrew's eyes light up right and so it's
just trying to think to that connection
to the people who are behind the camera
that's one two uh just because they
heard it two weeks ago it doesn't mean
they don't still need the message
right it's like especially with what
you're doing with addiction recovery
one day somebody might feel great and
then next day they're back to where they
used to be they need you every day and
like for everybody watching people need
your hope your inspiration every day
because they don't have those role
models in their lives so just because
they heard it two weeks ago it doesn't
mean okay I got it now
now I'm good now I never need to hear it
again
right I mean that'd be amazing if that
was actually how it worked but that's
not unfortunately how it works so most
people haven't heard the message before
but even if they have it doesn't mean
that they still don't need it again
today and so again it's it you might be
getting bored with it but it's putting
yourself in their shoes so that go back
to who you used to be when you're lying
and hiding things and you know cheating
on your values and all that stuff like
that Evan needs this Heaven you know
right now
um and then the third thing is just try
to challenge yourself to come up with
new stories just as a skill to learn so
when I'm making my videos sometimes it
always relates back to Foundation story
and depending on what the topic is but
I'll often push myself to try to think
okay what's happened in the past week
where I can share
something
so you've been thinking about what
happened to Nina this morning you know
and like having to
postpone movement makers at least me and
like rush to make all that happen that
could be a story for a video
so it's always a challenge to say okay
may not be as big a deal as me like
breaking my neck and going and
continuing the tour
but instead of always telling the break
in the next story I could tell this news
story it doesn't matter as much for the
audience I think it's just more for you
as a speaker as as a challenge to think
about okay where do I where do you still
doubt yourself even though you've been
sober for seven years or whatever it is
you know where do you still find
challenges where do you when have you
maybe almost thought about going back or
falling down and and sharing those kinds
of stories or something that's happened
you know recently
um just as a fun Challenge and improving
yourself as a speaker
yeah it was called covid
yeah
three uh seriously three and a half
years I I came close twice you really
did
well so share that story right like what
happened that led to that
and it may not be it's not as bad as
when you were in the depths of it but
people this is why I like showing the
vulnerability is really important
because people could look at you and say
well look at him he's got it all figured
out he's got this you know great
business this you know fancy suit on his
beautiful office he's got it all figured
out he's like no guys I almost went I
almost
relapsed
because this happened
because I lost a deal or because like
whatever was the thing that happened to
you people connect with that it's
another great story to share so
Kobe is great but even this week
something has happened this week that
again it may not be all the way down to
relapsing but where you doubted yourself
where you didn't do your morning routine
where you didn't show up like you wanted
to where you didn't work out as hard as
you wanted to you didn't make the calls
like you said you were going to do like
wherever you disappointed yourself or
let yourself down or had some negative
thoughts
that message is still going to be super
valuable and it's a it's a nice
challenge just to force yourself to tell
a news story doesn't mean you forget
about the old stuff that's still super
valuable but
I like it I think it's a good challenge
for yourself just to continue to improve
as a speaker
Rick what do you got hey everyone uh one
of the things you did talk about was the
the laminated like golden uh pyramid
that has the three level of Engagement
like okay okay
yeah yeah yeah Zan should have it uh the
bottom one is bottom layer is yes yes
yes uh personal connection and then
partnership and then thought leader
content creation
can any part of that pyramid actually be
I guess offloaded you know hire someone
to do any part of it or should I still
be you know controlling all three parts
of it
um all of it can at some point you have
to be involved in the process so for
example uh at the top is thought
leadership so
you could offs you could delegate out
the editing and the research and the
scripting and the caption and the
thumbnails and like whatever but you
have to be on camera or you have to like
your soul has to be in the thing uh if
it's going to be videos if it's going to
be written you could work with a writer
but your soul is the is the asset so you
have to sit there you still have to be
involved to like what is the message
going to be
to to get it out right but everything
else can be delegated Partnerships you
could have somebody reach out and ask
hey would you like to partner with Rick
would you like to have him on your show
would you like to hear more about what
Rick is doing right but at some point
like Rick has to show up to do the thing
right okay so just the mean part of it
where someone will make the call to like
basically yeah to schedule the time with
me so I still need to step into do the
actual the actual partner right
yeah you're the heart like you're the
heart so the heart has to come out so if
you have a budget to hire somebody
part-time or full-time then you look at
what do I like the least here's here are
the steps that have to happen what do I
not want to do in here what do I like
the least and that's when like what I
want to give up right so I I did not
like video editing it was my least
favorite thing to do so it was the first
person that I hired was a part-time
video editor and that let me move from a
video a week to a video a day because
now I didn't have to worry about editing
I could give that to somebody else to do
yeah but I still had to be
in front of the camera
right if you're going to be the leader
so
um yeah so just make a list and whatever
you don't like the that's whatever you
don't like the most as soon as you have
a budget you delegate that stuff out
great all right great
um second part uh second question I
guess uh very completely different
um you know regarding you know your
belief you know and yeah salsa dancing
they're like completely different things
right I mean you know you are being
quoted by at my lab to be the modern day
um
um you know uh Napoleon Hill right
as a beginner you know I'm building my
YouTube channel and all that stuff
naturally I would want to build videos
that are about my business what I'm good
at
um but I would have thought on your on
your end you would build videos on salsa
dancing teaching people how to dance but
instead you're DJing a lot of these
um mental well not mental strength but
more like uh you know a personal growth
belief type of videos to like basically
into your brain can you share shed some
light on you know the thought process on
this or like what should I do next type
of thing yeah so I mean it was super
humbling when when I met Ed at his house
um you know he invited me over and we
talked strategy and he said you're like
the modern day Napoleon Hill it's like
that's a can I use that can I quote you
on that
that's pretty awesome
um yeah and shout out to Evan tinsman
who's got Napoleon Hill right there on
his wall behind him that's the giant
face you know Napoleon Hill
um
I think the advantage you have is going
all in on you so I'm I'm always Evan
Carmichael I'm always trying to spread
believe there's a lot of different ways
that I do it
so in some rooms I'm the YouTube guy in
some rooms I'm the I'm the entrepreneur
DJ guy in some rooms I'm the salsa guy
in some rooms I'm the League of Legends
business guy it's all me
and
I think that's great like I think you
should have a hard time explaining who
you are and what you do right like when
somebody says hey
what are you doing who are you uh I
think I think it should be hard to
explain it if it were if you just say
well I'm an accountant or something
you're like nobody likes those boxes
um now I have a lot of different
channels because we have so much content
but if if I was you I would explore with
different kinds of content like I like
the DJ stuff and that was Gary B who
called me that right so I didn't come up
with that name either he's like you're
like the content DJ who inspires
people's like ooh can I use that
um that's what's of course you use them
and then you put it and they're banners
so that's why that's how I'm able to
re-quote it back to you right that yeah
well because I forgot what they said too
so it's nice to have the quote there as
a reminder for me too
um but that's what saved me right like
modeling success is the thing that saved
me and so now I I try to bring that
to my channel so that other people can
hopefully learn from it as well salsa
dancing is how I met Nina and you know I
I run the largest salsa dance studio at
least in Canada
um which is struggling right now because
of kobit like it's the least covered
friendly business in the world uh so
like the YouTube stuff is blowing up and
the salsa business is on life support
like let's get vaccinated and try to
make this business stay alive
um
but even the salsa business was never
about how to dance salsa so if you I I
taught at the school for a couple years
as well I thought the highest level
class
um it's how I met my wife Nina and every
now and then on movement makers we'll do
a little salsa dancing in advance when
Zane plays himself some music for us
which is super fun
um
but if you were to join the class it was
still belief
like joining My Salsa class I'm gonna
teach you some moves but I'm gonna I'm
gonna really teach you how to believe in
yourself more
because when you learn something that
you didn't think you could do you leave
a more confident person
like I'll show you how to I'll demo this
crazy move that you've never seen before
and you look at it and said wow that's
I'm never going to be able to do that
and then an hour later you're doing that
right so it's believe you don't join the
school just to learn moves you learn the
school to build friends become more
confident and believe in yourself more
so there's a lot of different ways and
why do I do that because that's how I I
gain belief
in doing that myself
because I went to salsa school and I
sucked and then I got better and I
learned and that gave me more belief in
myself so everything I do is believe I
just have different routes to do it I'll
do it through DJing content I'll do it
through my own thought leadership I'll
do it through movement makers I'll do it
through writing books I'll do it through
League of Legends we answer business
questions and help people believe while
you can watch me play games I do it
through salsa dancing everything is
belief
and so
whatever your who is it should flow
through everything that you make
and it's okay that some people nobody
not everybody knows that I can salsa
dance that's okay
when I go on shows they're like how do
you want me to introduce you to my
audience it's like whatever you want you
don't have to read my official bio
you know if you love that I made that
one video three years ago and that
changed your life perfect that's that's
how I want you to introduce me
right and so as long as like the thing
that's consistent is believe everybody
hopefully knows me for belief that's
what I want people if you want more
belief go connect with Evan follow up
and be a part of his Universe because
you're going to get more belief
uh so the question today was from Chris
who said what do you believe should be
our area of laser focus for online
businesses for the balance of the year
in terms of Engagement and growth I
think the biggest thing there is just
actually posting the content that you're
afraid to post like sharing the story
the message that you've got that you're
afraid of being judged on and post
um this is actually really timely
because this morning in movement makers
Zen before anybody showed up Zen played
this song called patapata which is this
South African song
um
the artist was known as the the mama of
Africa and and I love that song and uh
it's a Cha-Cha song that that I Nina and
I danced to a lot and Zen didn't know
that I liked that song and so after we
got off movement makers that song which
is in my head in my head in my head in
my head in my head and so I decided for
some reason that I needed to learn the
lyrics of that song because I kind of
hummed along you know when it's a song
in a different language you don't quite
know what they're saying so I said
and there's like one line in English and
that's the one that you always get
anyway so
I I then committed an hour today on a
day that I don't have an hour to learn
the lyrics of patapata
and I and I I started filming it on my
Instagram stories to ask for help like
does anybody speak this language does
anybody know because it sounds like some
of the syllables she's saying she's
she's skipping it she's not actually
seeing it so I'm stressed out like I'm
trying to figure out how do I get this
song out
and and now I'm I'm asking for help and
then I keep I keep at it keep at it slow
the song down to 50 percent
slowly going like syllable by syllable
until I finally feel like I got it so
then I share guys I think I got it I
think she's this this thi is silent
and then I keep practicing keep
practicing keep practicing and then I
get the full speed and I film it it's
like here I am full speed and I'm
rocking and rocking out on the on my
trampoline singing patapatin you know in
this language I don't understand and
then I get so animated that I hit my
phone and it falls down and that's the
end of the video and and I shared the
whole thing on my Instagram story
and like that's the type of content that
people don't often get to see that's the
kind of content that we're afraid to
post that's the kind of content that
we're afraid of being judged for it's
like I thought you're supposed to be
some business Guru what are you doing
spending an hour learning some song that
that's the thing that humanizes you
the question was about engagement and
growth like that's how you get engaged
in a growth is showing The Human Side Of
You the thing that if that was me five
years ago I would have been incredibly
embarrassed to share that I'm singing I
don't have a good voice singing voice so
I'm singing out loud to some language
that I don't know probably making
mistakes all over the place
dancing on my trampoline and smashing my
phone over right it's like the most
imperfect thing ever but that moment of
creativity and posted people are already
damning me with like reactions laughing
celebration party more than a typical
story would get more than just a guys
today you need to focus let me talk
about Focus for the day right so the
most engaging in growth content is the
stuff that you are afraid to share your
story creativity the the creative idea
that you've got there in your mind that
like oh I could never post that like
that's the thing to post and then that's
the thing to post consistently and
that's what will draw you in like your
Humanity your vulnerability your those
stories other things that will
make people love you and want to dive
deeper into your world it doesn't mean
this is where people struggle like how
do I show how do I be the expert but
then also show that I don't have all the
answers and I'm still afraid
a lot of people like if you look on
Instagram it's just that everybody looks
perfect and The Branding is perfect and
the cars and everything is perfect
when you're too perfect people actually
can't connect to you
they need to know that you're a human
and in your humanness is the the then
permission for people to actually listen
to your advice because people won't
listen you might have all the best
advice in the world but people won't
listen to your advice until they know
that you're like them
and so that's the content that we're the
most afraid to share because we don't
want to go back to being that person
we're embarrassed by this stuff about
ourselves
but in sharing that is the thing that
opens up the world to you to get that
growth and engagement so back to the
question of what's the most engagement
content for the for the rest of the year
that's what I would focus on the stuff
that you're afraid to post sharing your
story taking me deep inside your
insecurities vulnerabilities show me you
doing the things that you do that make
you human that people really connect
with that's my thought of the day with
your questions now obviously turn it
over to you guys so you put your hand up
try to get to as many as I can Niles
already got his hand ready to go what do
you got man thanks this is awesome and I
love that this is uh that's so that's
something I've been struggling with I'll
be honest with you but at the same time
and so I'm going to ask a technical
question I asked you this in the past
somewhere else but when it comes to the
actual tracks that you use because I my
background I love to dance dance fitness
is actually my background and now I'm
moving somewhat away from it but I love
it and I still want to show that playful
side and that was a big part of my life
so I want to be able to show that again
technical side was the actual uh I love
that you're dancing there
um the idea is um uh technical side how
long is a track allowed did you use the
real track or did you get an edit of
that actual song because I love that
song too but I'm not that I'll use it I
want to get an idea of what what will
actually put a red band against me
yeah yeah great question and Nile
if it becomes your business then you you
start doing the research in the work
some tracks some companies care a lot
some companies care zero for me because
I'm not in the music like music is not
my my game
um I just recorded it on Instagram it
was a IG live story and and those don't
get typically picked up or banned or
anything
um if I were to turn it into a YouTube
video it might I don't know patapata is
a pretty obscure
song that most people don't really know
about but if you did if you pulled the
Taylor Swift song it's probably going to
get
blocked or demonetized right those are
the two options either block it or they
demonetize it so at the beginning though
don't let that stifle the creativity
I made the I was feeling that song
Because Zane put it in my head so now I
have to dedicate an hour to figure out
the lyrics to this song and and I was
frustrated and I slow it down and I
speed it up and then I finally get it
and you get to see how happy I am that I
knock over the phone and it's just so
exciting and that will live fine on
Instagram and even if it just disappears
in 24 hours and I don't do anything else
with it awesome if I download it and
turn into a YouTube video maybe that
gets blocked and it doesn't see the
light of day but if I'm going to keep
doing it then I'd have to pick songs
that are going to get through
and that becomes the business to know
which songs get through but at the
beginning don't let those questions
stifle the creative output because if I
spent that time thinking I wonder if
this song is going to get blocked I
wonder if this is gonna then I don't
make the song and then that moment is
gone right right so we just start
overthinking right away from the
beginning instead of just creating and
yes you'll make some mistakes I mean I
didn't think I didn't mic myself up I
didn't set up a cat like the camera when
I'm doing the full shot I'm only on like
the bottom half because I don't have the
the stand to make it happen right
overthinking all that stuff then leads
to the creativity going away and then
nothing gets created
instead of this magical moment that was
created right so it's gonna be your
business you have to know it otherwise
go create go make you'll learn as you go
yeah thanks Evan appreciate it cool uh
iPhone has her hand raised welcome
iPhone
this is the first time I have uh the
courage to to show my face now she's
doing it ladies and gentlemen
good job I love it I love salsa I'm in
Vancouver Canada I danced every weekend
on the beach nice yes salsa on the beach
is hard
yeah we we have a concrete like oh okay
okay good because salsa on Sand is you
can't turn for anything so that's good I
love it yes yes I'm following you on the
salsa scene as well but uh um my name is
Olivia I've been hiding but now I'm
coming out but there's an opportunity to
partner with uh with company I'm doing
tonight my dream is to do interesting
training and I know that my purpose is
the language this company's purpose they
have a lot of size like presence
Christian Missionary Training healthcare
workers but not nursing project I'm
expanding their Market to China but
we've been talking for a few months and
they're not paying me anything and then
now they give me a I I asked for then
the man last like don't sign a
non-disclosure agreement they want me to
work exclusive with them without a pay
structure or a partnership contract but
it is my passion and I've been trying to
take off for over 10 years and I
couldn't by myself should I just like
keep on serving them and giving them for
free or should I say like a draw a line
understand say you know you pay me as a
consultant or an employee or let's draft
up a contract so first off
I wouldn't sign an NDA that prevents you
from working with other companies
because you your passion I would split
this up like your passion is to be in
this space
your passion isn't to be with this one
company
there's lots of companies who you could
do this thing with
your passion is being the space so
anything that prevents you from being in
this space
that locks you into one company
especially unpaid I'm not a fan of if
you look at what I do with with YouTube
stuff I've seen
everybody's channels
I don't I don't sign ndas for anybody
when I was in a venture capital business
I saw so many deals of different
businesses we never signed an NDA
because it becomes your reputation
if you screw one person over or you
share details of somebody that
damages your entire reputation like if
Zane the man built to serve coach if
he's out sharing oh you know what Olivia
said to me in our private session last
week it's like then then it's over like
his entire reputation as a coach is gone
you have to keep
information confidential that becomes
your reputation
um so definitely taking anything out
that's exclusivity
I like the idea of doing free work at
the beginning
if if people don't recognize your value
the thing with free work is you have to
do free work with ideal clients
so at the beginning you're doing the
free work you're building up a
reputation you get into you prove
yourself but is this an ideal client who
can ultimately pay you and they might be
doing the ideal work that you want to
get into but they may not be the ideal
client for you you're already shaking
your head so yeah they were like we
don't have any funding and I was like
well let's draft a like uh like you know
we split the cost and the you know the
revenue they're like but we don't know
what's how much how many students you
can get and market and so there's
nothing set yeah go ahead
so you want to be in the space and doing
free work is great to start but they
have to be with ideal clients so if it's
not this client
then it's finding more people now you
have something to show now now you've
done it I mean it's great don't don't
feel like you made this terrible
decision now you've got some experience
in the field that you can point to now
you've built some extra contacts and
connections now you've built some
momentum and you've also shown to
yourself that you really do like this
when you're just looking at it you don't
know if you actually love it but now
you're in it's like I actually do love
this thing now it's a matter of finding
more companies to work with not being
tied down to this one client that
doesn't like it's not even the it's not
having funding is one thing but also not
being willing to work something out it's
a mindset shift too right yeah but it's
just that's not who those are not the
ideal clients that you want to be
chasing down so if I'm going to be
looking at okay who are
10 other companies that are trying to do
the same thing and how can I go and yes
prove myself at the beginning even if
it's free work but that I provide so
much value that I want to work with them
um even using xan as an example he he
joined my YouTube gaming live streams uh
where we play League of Legends and
answer questions and he he brought so
much value that then I'm looking for
like how do I help Zan out more like how
do I love this guy I love collecting
good people how do we do something
together so the starting point was
connecting with other people I can't get
him to Jason's like hey you need to do
an IG live with Jason who's Jason don't
worry about it you're gonna love him
he's great you guys are kind of hungry
both have like the biggest Smiles in the
world the biggest hearts in the world
you'll love each other right so he's
like all right igdm's Jason and they do
their thing that then LED Suzanne you
know becoming the Builder serve coach
so that's that's doing free work and
building your reputation to the point
where opportunities happen but if if the
people in the company aren't giving you
opportunities
and they're just making you work for
free and sign non-disclosure and
exclusivity agreements it's just not the
right fit so now it's just branching out
find 10 other companies who are doing
similar things where you can come and
bring your value to help them
and then work your path towards getting
paid for it
yeah there's a thing about Christian
there's a lot of volunteers serving it's
just not the business mentality and I
really want to combine the two but you
know it's hard to find in a space maybe
it's just my scarcity I thought oh
they're Christians you know values are
aligned you know so yeah but listen
there's a lot of people who will have
values aligned that just may not be a
Christian organization like there may be
a for-profit there's a lot of for-profit
companies run by Christians who have
strong values
right okay okay so those are the people
who you might want to search out instead
of always living in the non-profit world
I love non-profit I love free like what
are we doing here this is free you guys
bought
a book for 15 bucks or something or some
of you might have just pirated it
so this but this but in order to do this
in order to do the free stuff you have
to also have an income stream to support
you and your organization and the more
you build up mini constream the more
your team can also contribute you know
Sandra my assistant is in here and she
sets all this stuff up for me so I can
afford to hire her to do this to allow
me to come here and do this right so
there's lots of organizations who are
who are making money who also like not
every company has a has a devil Soul
right they're living the the mission the
values but also
uh are making money and and would love
what you're bringing you just have to do
the work to go find those people
thank you so much you're amazing yeah
cool good luck and hey welcome welcome
thank you for turning on your camera for
the first time and asking a question
that's great that's what it's all about
thank you uh who's next Jose what do you
got uh so uh great to see you
um just wanted to ask a quick I have a
couple of questions but I'm gonna ask
more now and if there's more time and I
can come back to it great
um in the book when you talked about uh
when you uh you know uh left your first
company with your partner and then you
realize what you're going to do you
decided to model you the success after
Bill Gates and you talked about how you
uh focused on uh forming Partnerships
and alliances and I just wanted to get
maybe a little bit more feedback on that
like specifically I'm in the process of
starting a um a nationwide quick service
restaurant
um with a healthy uh approach and so
I've been uh I've been one one way that
I formed a partner alliances was
bringing it to a fold an old business
colleague who has over 20 years a
marketing experience
um and I partnered up with him to kind
of like you know help me in the form of
the company and and being Partners but
I'm trying to figure out
just a little bit more on that like if
you were starting a quick service
wrestling I guess I mean what might be
some of the Partnerships and alliances
that you might look to to form
so
what I meant in the book wasn't so much
bring a business partner into your
company because that's like getting
married so most business Partnerships
fail because people look at well they
have this skill set and I have this
skill set it's going to be perfect
Meanwhile your values are completely
different
and so you're in the dating phase hey
you have 50 I have 50 let's start this
company together but because the values
are a mismatched it really is like you
need to date before you get married so
I'd be I'd be it's not that Partnerships
can't work out just you need to treat it
like it's going to be a marriage you
might spend more time during the week
with them than your husband or wife
right I mean that just a reality of
starting the business so you better
really like them
um so it doesn't mean don't make that
partnership but I would test something
small work on one thing together before
you go and do some big thing together
like what's the first step that you guys
can take together
um there's a guy who emailed me to say
hey I want to help you with your email
marketing okay great write me write me
one email
and see what it looks like and I liked
it so then I hired him to do 10 emails
okay great so now we're going to see
what he comes up with with for his 10
emails and if maybe I the more people
hang around me the more I just start
businesses with them
right it's like this is what I love to
do we Zan now has a business together
Drew has a business together like Alex
all these people like the more time we
spend together the more I'm looking for
opportunities and we just it just
gravitates towards doing some kind of
company together but it always starts
with something small at the beginning
okay so that's what I would do with him
or her like something small at the
beginning to make sure that you work
well together well he and I like I said
we've had a long time relationship for
about 15 years and we've worked together
um and and so yeah I'm figuring that out
and I definitely value that feedback but
in terms of like the the company itself
like what how would I go about then
let's say procurement types of
Partnerships in the line so that would
be correct for the brand that don't
involve equity and partnership yeah so
you're looking at how do I start for me
if it were me how do I start this
business spending the least amount of
money possible restaurants are are the
worst it's like it's the number one
failure business in America
and especially now right so I'll be
looking I'd look into what Mr Beast is
doing ghost kitchens
that's exactly what we're doing yeah I
mean that's that makes a ton of sense
find people who restaurants are
struggling right now you find the
companies who can make your product
whatever you're selling whose ethics and
values kind of fit with what you're
doing and find a way to connect
you don't have to worry about going like
Nationwide yet but you start what city
are you in I'm in Philly and I'm looking
to open either in Philly uh and or Miami
yeah but like do Philly you're in Philly
don't worry about Miami how you gonna do
Miami you got a flat you got to be in
Miami like you got to make it happen
Philly's a big enough market definitely
you're not in some tiny little rural
middle nowhere right so you're in Philly
so you start you want to actually go and
meet restaurant owners and Pitch them
the idea and the model's already been
proven
people are already doing this and
restaurants are struggling right now to
figure out a business opportunity and if
they can make some extra money without
having to do
you know a lot of extra work they're not
spending any time marketing they already
have the staff and the team and the
ingredients and everything else right
that's your best bet and then make prove
it in Philly
and then you might need five locations
in Philly
and then worry about Miami but I
probably go somewhere closer to Philly
just for your own sanity and traveling
and all that stuff
sure thank you so much make sense uh
how's our time lady Lexi quick what do
you got I was asking you something about
extension
uh and then ask you about that club you
said no dot Club is for uh clubhouse so
um are the only ones suitable the ones
you end with.com for General websites or
can we also use for instance dot life
dot com is just the the standard that's
what people
I would I would default to a.com if you
can or put your name just find some way
to get a.com like a DOT live so I use
Evan carmichael.live we have one if you
want to go to my live gaming channel
tonight 6 p.m Eastern you type in Evan
carmichael.live it'll forward to the
YouTube stream
the especially with DOT live and in
Movie Makers usfl.com
dot Club the perception is it's a
clubhouse thing
dot live the perception is it's a live
thing so if you're going to be pointing
if it's lady lexi.live the perception is
you're going to lead me to a live stream
of some kind
that's going to go to your Instagram
where you're going live or a YouTube
channel where you're going live but if
it's just a website and you're not going
live it's just a disconnect
so I don't I don't I mean.com is ideal
if you're going to go dot net or dot us
or dot whatever it can all still work I
think honestly the website is becoming
less and less important
something
dot-com is taken that that's what the
thing is and I can't reach the owner
yeah so she just transfers it to her
Facebook page and I know there's also
the life with an f and since I always
talk about lady Lexi's live on the road
yeah lady Lexi something
lady Lexi whatever else.com uh and keep
you if it so if you really want to chase
it down you can I mean Brendan burchard
tells the story of it took him six years
I think to get brendan.com
where he just every three months emailed
the guy again like hey if you wanna if
you're ready to sell hey if you're ready
to sell hey if you're ready to sell the
guy who owns evan.com
is not using it it's it's forwards to
some hotel in Germany or or Russia or
something I don't know or maybe Holland
I don't know it just forwards to someone
they're not using it
right but I don't care enough about
evan.com and if Evan Carmichael was
taken I would I would have it believe
Carmichael it's like it almost doesn't
matter
more important is you creating the
content building your brand but I I
think the only thing you want to do is
not create confusion if you put a dot
club or dot live it creates confusion
true it was like the name I don't think
a company name really matters that much
like what did Evan Carmichael mean
before Evan Carmichael what is what did
Xerox mean like the guy who made Xerox
picked his name because he wanted a name
so difficult to pronounce that once you
got it you wouldn't forget it
like
x-e-r-o-x is crazy what kind of name is
that how do you pronounce that you look
at it on the sheet you have no idea what
that means but once you got it you don't
forget Jason Wells right everybody
messes up Jason nobody puts Y and Jason
right it's a weird spelling but in his
branding it's all about the why and so
you remember oh why because his his
purpose-driven brand helps you figure
out your your why and so his why you
know he he made that work for him so
Jason Wells with the Y now is easy to
know that that's who it is versus any
other Jason out there so the brain is
what you make it you just don't want to
have
when you attach yourself to something
that already has meaning
it means something
when you create something brand new you
can attach the meeting you want in
American you know election debates the
the presidents or the president to be
always has the pin of the U.S flag
because the U.S flag means something
so they're trying to attach themselves
to that symbol so when you're using
symbols or extensions that have meaning
you have to make sure you match the
meaning
otherwise you create a new symbol
you know the the airplane means
something to me I mean it might have
some kind of meaning but in general the
people don't really know what it means
I'm assigning meaning to it the name
Evan Carmichael I'm assigning meaning to
it so I I'm okay with anything pick
whatever you want I just don't want to
confuse people
um in the process because you're picking
a name that doesn't represent or like an
extension doesn't represent your actual
brand
okay cool thank you if you want to get a
copy of build to serve and join us live
for our next training with me to ask
your questions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love